bonjour je vous invite à vous tourner
vers votre voisin et prendre quelques
secondes pour vous poser mutuellement la
question que fais tu dans la vie
alors
mais
je vois vous faites connaissance c'est
chouette hein
comme j'ai quand même je dois continuer
désolé qui parmi vous a entendu une
réponse qui se référait à une activité
professionnelle
je vous propose de changer le monde
en apprenant à répondre différemment à
la question à cette question que fais tu
dans la vie la plupart d'entre vous
avait parlé de votre travail
comme si la vie se résumait à notre
travail
mais au fond qu'est ce que c'est le
travail le travail c'est prendre une
petite quantité de matière sur la terre
et le transformer le déplacer en faire
un produit ou indirectement un service
historiquement le travail de tous
étaient nécessaires afin de garantir la
survie de l'humanité
si quelqu'un ne travaillait pas
c'était un poids mort et il était
généralement exclus de la communauté
et puis petit à petit nous avons
commencé à optimiser notre travail à
produire plus en travaillant moins
l'industrialisation a été un tel gain de
productivité que le travail de tous est
devenue de moins en moins nécessaire
cependant on ne balaie pas d'un revers
de main les stigmates de millénaires
d'un système social
aujourd'hui encore la plupart d'entre
nous veulent avoir un travail de peur
d'être exclu de la société de peur
peut-être de perdre leur identité mais
si la productivité augmente
comment faire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse avoir un travail
deux solutions la première c'est de
consommer plus on va créer des nouveaux
besoins
c'est ce qu'on appelle la théorie
économique de la croissance alors pour
deux raisons qui vont sans doute vous
semblez particulièrement évidente la
croissance et par quitter rue est
stupide sauf si vous êtes politiciens
la première raison c'est que consommer
prend du temps en belgique
notre espérance de vie est de deux
milliards et demi de seconde
cela signifie que il existe une limite
matériel à ce que nous pouvons consommer
au delà d'un certain seuil
nous n'avons matériellement plus assez
de secondes de vie pour pouvoir
consommer mais il est plus important
la terre c'est une quantité limitée de
matière avec des capacités de recyclage
également limité travailler et consommer
cela revient à transformer une petite
partie de la planète en déchets la
croissance n'est donc pas simplement
économiquement absurde c'est également
la destruction pure et simple de notre
planète
heureusement j'ai parlé d'une deuxième
solution afin que chacun puisse avoir de
l'emploi eh bien nous allons tout
simplement être le plus inefficace
possible oui on va annuler les gains de
productivité de l'industrialisation en
rajoutant des couches d'inefficacité la
bureaucratie la structure managériale la
réglementation nous sommes très créatif
quand il s'agit d'être inefficace
moi j'appelle ça le creusage et
rebouchage des trous si vous êtes
politiciens et que vous voulez créer de
l'emploi
rien de plus facile vous demandez à
quelqu'un de creuser des trous puis vous
demander une deuxième personne de
reboucher les trous
vous venez de créer deux emplois
bravo la seule subtilité c'est de faire
en sorte que les les deux ne se croisent
jamais comme ça ils ont l'impression
d'être utile donc vous rigolez mais j'ai
connu une entreprise où il y avait des
gens au service achats qui se contentait
de passer leur temps à passer les
commandes pour une partie du service
informatique qui s'occupait de la
maintenance de leurs ordinateurs
alors moi j'ai dit comme ça en rigolant
à la cantine si on supprime ces
postes-là personnes dans l'entreprise ne
s'en rendra compte il ya eu un silence
et on m'a rétorqué tu ne voudrais quand
même pas mettre nos collègues au chômage
l'inefficacité serait-elle donc la
solution non
car tout comme la croissance
l'inefficacité à deux problèmes le
premier c'est on a beau être le plus
efficace possible et aujourd'hui on est
bon et bien les emplois continuent à
disparaître les bientôt l'intelligence
artificielle pourra sans doute remplacer
la plupart des êtres humains à
l'intelligence artificielle peut être
déjà conduire des voitures puis écrit
des romans ont posé de la musique
répondre à nos emails répondre aux
emails envoyés par d'autres
intelligences artificielles
j'ai discuté avec un professeur
d'université qui était très fier parce
que une de ses pièces allaient bientôt
être jouée à londres
une pièce de théâtre et c'est pas lui
qui l'avait écrite
c'était un de ses logiciels
l'inefficacité et donc inefficace mais
plus fondamentalement nous avons beau le
cas chez nous nous rendons compte au
fond de nous que tout cela n'a aucun
sens
selon un récent sondage de l'institut
gallup au niveau mondial nous sommes
seulement 13% à être investis par notre
travail plus de 60 % aimeraient changer
de travail et un travailleur sur quatre
déteste profondément ce qu'il fait salut
que fais tu dans la vie je fais des
choses que je déteste voir que je
réprouve moralement mais il faut bien
travailler
nous travaillons toute la journée dans
une usine d'armement et le soir nous
allons militer dans une association
pacifiste
après quelques années d abuser nous
abandonnons l'association quand nous
cherchons à créer de l'emploi
au fond nous dépensons notre énergie
pour détruire la planète et pour faire
en sorte que le plus de gens possible
face des choses inutiles qui n'ont aucun
sens faire ce qu'on pourrait pas
imaginer autre chose que l'inefficacité
breton comment imaginer une société
différente car après tout le camp on y
réfléchit ça a du sens le plein emploi
ce n'est jamais qu'une fine fine ligne
entre d'un côté la misère la famine et
de l'autre le chômage est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que se garder en
équilibre instable sur cette étroite
frontière soit un projet de société
durable
mais comment créer une société basée sur
l'abondance
comment inventer une société pour un
monde où il ya plus de gens qui meurent
d'avoir trop consommer que de n'avoir
pas assez aujourd'hui sur la planète il
ya plus de personnes qui souffrent
d'obésité que de malnutrition une idée
que j'aime beaucoup
c'est leur revenu de base après tout si
notre ambition ses terres en sorte que
chacun puisse vivre décemment
pourquoi ne pas lui offrir sans
condition un salaire minimum mais
suffisant pour tout pour tous
inconditionnel bah oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui en belgique si vous
voulez toucher le chômage
vous devez prouver que vous ne
travaillez pas il existe des gens payés
par nos impôts dont le métier est de
s'assurer que vous n'avez aucune
activité même l'aîné vol autre que
chercher en emploi
le revenu de base sa part est une utopie
impayable mais des dizaines
d'économistes se penche sur la question
depuis des décennies et pourrait
peut-être être financés rien qu'avec la
simplification administrative qui
s'ensuivrait et la suppression des aides
à la création d'emplois parce que entre
nous souvent les aides à la création
d'emplois elle coûte plus cher à l'état
que ce qu'elle rapporte aux travailleurs
alors le revenu de base est déjà testée
en finlande dans certaines villes des
pays bas lothario une province du canada
vient d'annoncer un programme pilote de
donner un salaire à tout le monde sans
condition la suisse réfléchit
sérieusement la question
d'ailleurs le gros débat c'est de savoir
à combien va se monter ce revenu de base
j'aimerais reprendre les mots de
philippe van parijs professeur à
l'université de louvain qui a dit un
jour nous nous demanderons comment nous
avons pu vivre sans revenu de base
oui un jour le monde sans revenu de base
me paraîtra barbares préhistorique
inhumain car les expériences menées ont
montré que avec un revenu de base
les humains sont plus créatifs plus
entreprenants plus solidaire est
nettement plus heureux à plus feignants
ouais aller mais si nous voulons changer
le monde
si nous voulons changer le monde nous
devons apprendre à être feignant car il
ne vous reste que quelques dizaines ou
centaines de millions de seconde à vivre
qu'aimeriez vous en faire qu'aimeriez
vous répondre la prochaine fois qu'on
vous pose la question
que fais tu dans la vie que fais tu dans
la vie je fais des choses qui ont du
sens pour moi et j'essaie modestement de
rendre mon monde meilleur
et peut-être aussi le vôtre